[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLIFF REDEKER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to another amazing
Talks at Google event.
My name is Cliff Redeker
and I have the privilege
of discussing today
the new film out
called "Score," which is a
journey through the history
of film composing
and the interplay
between the visual
medium and the audio.
And we're very
thrilled today to be
joined by both the
director, Matt Schrader,
as well as one of the
composers featured
in the film, Joe Kramer.
So I'd like to invite them
both to join me on stage
and we'll have a few questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CLIFF REDEKER: Great.
I think you'll
have to hit the on
button just on the
side there, just
to make sure that we're live.
So I was wondering if
you could first tell me
a little bit about the film--
what the inspirations were,
and probably most
importantly, since it's
a film about music film
composition, how did
you score the score?
MATT SCHRADER: Yeah, we jumped
into this as, really, fans--
somewhat educated fans,
but not that educated.
And we thought it would
be worthwhile to take
a plunge into this topic.
It's something that
kind of amazingly
had not been done
before as a documentary.
And we had several conversations
about a lot of this
and realized there's
an incredible depth--
obviously, it's
such an immersive,
kind of creative art
form in the first place.
But it hasn't really--
hasn't really been
dived into before.
And so we actually wanted to
try to allow some of the great
examples of film scores
throughout the years,
throughout decades-- the really,
last 100 years probably--
be the focal point, the
thing that we share.
We came into this
thinking we probably
don't need an original score.
At the end, we realized
we kind of did.
We needed something to at least
fill a few different areas
where it made a lot of
sense, especially where we're
explaining something that
needs something to carry
that just a little bit.
But I think that's largely it.
We wanted the
focal point of this
to really be the work over the
last many, many decades that
have made a big impact
on-- not just musicians,
not just people in film,
but also all of pop culture.
CLIFF REDEKER: Exactly.
And I also want to
delve a little bit more
into the art form as well.
If you approach it as one of the
largest employers of orchestras
these days, it's definitely
in the classical tradition.
But at the same time,
how did that diverge
from pure classical music?
You have Handel's
water music, you
have a few big capital
letter composers
that compose for
film, that then seems
to have split a little bit.
And now it's actually
on the way back,
where you have Nobue
Uematsu in concert,
or Hans Zimmer in an auditorium.
So how did that journey happen?
JOE KRAMER: Well, I
think what happened
is that we saw a
decline in attendance
in classical orchestra concerts.
So city orchestras
across America
were seeing radical
drops in attendance.
At the same time,
the young concert
goers that they were
trying to attract
were interested
in seeing concerts
with music from "The Legend
of Zelda" or "Final Fantasy."
And that's where I
first saw it happening,
was with video games.
And so you'd go
to a concert hall,
and there'd be the
audience filled
with people dressed as Link.
You know what I mean?
And they'd be there
to hear the score
from the Wind Waker performed
live with a symphony orchestra.
And then at the 20th
anniversary of "E.T.,"
Williams did the
score live to picture.
And it was the first time I'd
seen it done in a concert,
ever.
And it was a huge success
and it took a while
for all the studios'
legal departments
to make all the arrangements
but that became another thing.
And so what we're seeing
now, the next step
was doing an entire
film live to picture.
And the New York
Philharmonic is getting
ready to do four Star
Wars movies this fall.
The Hollywood Bowl
every summer is doing--
last summer I think they did
"E.T." and "Harry Potter."
They're doing two or
three movies a year.
I saw them do "2001"
live, which was amazing.
John Williams, as the
conductor of the Boston Pops,
was always incorporating
specially adapted suites
of his film music
into the show--
into the shows.
And you saw once in a while,
like, "Gone with the Wind"
would be on a program.
But they were
usually Pops concerts
that were divided from
the classical thing.
And what I would think would
be interesting would be,
that in a way, the classic--
they start sneaking
a classical piece
into one of these concerts
that's video game music.
It wouldn't-- it would be
harder to do in a concert where
they're showing the film.
But if you just
had a concert where
it was like two hours of music
from all the Star Wars movies,
without visual,
and then you said,
we're going to
throw some Mars in,
some of the planets in there--
[INAUDIBLE] you know.
That could be an interesting way
to then reignite kid's interest
in the classical composers.
I mean, the challenge
is that the language
of contemporary film
music is so radically
different from the language
of classical music.
There's a big gulf between the
kind of melodic contrapuntal
writing that
Beethoven was doing,
and what you're hearing in
"Pirates of the Caribbean."
it's like Mitchell Loeb says.
It's Led Zeppelin
with an orchestra.
CLIFF REDEKER: And then also
I think it separates the art
form, as well.
Like, composing for film
has inherent constraints
by definition.
The movie is only so long.
You're tying it
into certain clips.
How do you work within
that constraint, expand it?
And then if you're doing
a suite or re-arrangement,
what's your approach when you
cut out the visual component?
JOE KRAMER: Well, Yeah.
People always marvel at
how much John Williams
music works on its own terms.
But-- and it's not to put it
down, he's sort of-- for me,
he's sort of the
pinnacle of the art form.
He makes specific
arrangements for concerts.
And they're versions
that you don't really
ever hear in the movie the way
you hear them at Symphony Hall.
You know what I mean?
It's almost like making a hit
single out of a Broadway show,
where the song is never
performed that way in the show
but you've made a single
of it for the radio.
What was the--
CLIFF REDEKER: How you work
within the constraint itself?
JOE KRAMER: So, yeah--
CLIFF REDEKER: You
know, two hours--
JOE KRAMER: To me,
it's not a constraint.
For me, actually, it's
a helpful skeleton
to hang musical ideas on.
So say for example, in
"Mission Impossible,"
there's a sequence where
Ethan Hunt, played by Tom--
the opening scene where
he jumps on the wing
of that airplane and then
hangs on to it as it takes off.
You have these sort of
signposts along the way
that guide, and for me
inform, the structure
of what I'm writing.
So we have the studio cards
at the very beginning that
say Paramount Pictures, Sky
Dance Pictures, et cetera, et
cetera, Bad Robot.
And then we have the
shot of the field.
And then Benji pops up.
And then conversation begins and
we're cutting back and forth.
And all of those
events become markers
in my timeline in the computer
that I use to write my music.
And it becomes sort of a
binary process of saying, well,
is it fast or slow?
Is it brass or strings?
Is it light or dark?
Is it funny or tense?
And before I know
it, I go, OK, so I've
got to write 12 seconds of funny
string medium tempo music--
go.
And then-- and then--
but when you have that--
when you have a set of criteria
that you have to satisfy,
you know-- as programmers,
you would all know that.
If you've got to make
a little applet that
does this specific
thing, you've got that.
And in just the
same way that you
have APIs built into
however you're programming,
and dialog boxes that
are built into the OS,
I've got those tricks
in music that I
know will let me communicate.
Because what I'm trying to do
is communicate to the audience--
essentially, a score is
a second language track
that you're hearing
underneath the dialogue.
And it's telling the story.
And it's informing the
audience of connections
between characters, of
where we are in the world,
of how we're supposed to
be interpreting what we're
seeing on an emotional level.
And I'm trying to get at your
subconscious using a shorthand
that's been developed--
CLIFF REDEKER: It triggers
the emotional reaction, yeah.
And of course, thank you for
calling programming an art.
We like to think it's
an art here, too.
So mission accomplished.
But--
JOE KRAMER: Don't say that.
CLIFF REDEKER: But then
I was also curious too,
if you could describe just the
general process when you're--
are you approached
to score these films?
Like is there-- are there
auditions or demo reel?
Like, what's the--
how does it go
from a germ of an idea to you at
the piano to you in the studio?
JOE KRAMER: Ideally,
what happens is,
somebody has heard music that
I've done for another film
and they're just
so in love with it
that they've got
to have me score
their movie no matter what.
And they call me and say, we
want you to score this movie.
That never happens.
What happens is, I hear
that they're making a movie
and I go, I think I'd like
to try to work on that.
And I-- either I call them
directly or through my agent,
we reach out to them and
see if they're interested,
if they've hired somebody.
It's not a business that is--
oddly enough, it's not a
career that is really driven
by the person who's doing it.
I can't force a director to
hire me to score their movie.
And I don't have the
means at my disposal
to write and direct
and make movies,
just so I could score them.
So I'm sort of at the mercy
of the people who are hiring.
And in my experience, that's
principally directors.
Studio executives obviously
play a part in that,
producers play a part in that.
In the case of
"Mission Impossible,"
Tom Cruise played
a part in that,
because the franchise
is his baby.
But ultimately, it was--
Chris McQuarrie is the
director of that film--
that made the decision.
And similarly, I did the
score for "Jack Reacher"
with Chris McQuarrie.
Tom-- Chris loved the
score, Tom loved the score.
By all accounts,
everybody loved the score.
When Ed Zwick was
approached to direct
the sequel, the first
thing he told everybody is,
I don't want to bring anybody
back from the first movie.
If I take this job, I want
to have a fresh start.
Which means no-- new
photographer, new editor,
new production design, new
costume design, new composer.
And no matter how much
I wanted to do the film
and how much maybe
even Tom or Sky
Dance or Paramount would
have liked me to do the film,
it was the director's call.
CLIFF REDEKER: Interesting.
And I think it's also worth
pointing out that a lot of this
comes under very short notice
from the time you get the call.
You're in the studio
within a matter of weeks.
You're recording it
How do you work under those
deadlines and stay creative?
JOE KRAMER: You eat a lot.
So there's-- and then
when you're not working,
you drink a lot.
There's a certain element
of craftsmanship to it.
We all have in our brain,
maybe, the perfect game
that we want to
create for Chrome.
We all have the idea of what
would be the perfect Google
App for the title page.
And then when we get the call
to do it, we're suddenly like,
I don't--
I don't know what to do.
I had all these
great ideas and now
I suddenly can't
think what would
be the perfect game
for me to define myself
as a programmer for
the Google title page.
You know what I mean?
Similarly, with composing,
I have all these ideas
and then I get the call and
it's a movie that I never
thought I would be asked to
work on, or a kind of music.
I'm like, how did they hear
what I've done and think,
this is what I--
I'm the guy for this?
What's nice is, it frees
up your thinking because
in any creative endeavor,
what you're trying to do
is get past the censor in your
head that saying that's dumb,
that's stinks, that's
not going to work.
So you're-- I I'm--
and I have the, like I said,
the craftsmanship tricks
or sparks, help spark my
memory, or my creative thinking,
that I can rely on.
Like, the binary decision--
fast, slow, light, dark, happy,
sad.
There's a whole evil concept
lurking beneath the whole film
world which the film
doesn't really get into,
which is temporary music
that's been cut into the film.
And oftentimes that
can be instructive.
It can also be hand-cuffs,
but at its best,
it's instructive
in helping people
talk about something that's hard
to talk about, which is music.
CLIFF REDEKER: And we
actually had a question
from Dave down in our
Los Angeles office
with that very same idea,
the idea of temp tracks.
And what do you do
when the director says,
I really love the temp track.
Make something like it.
Or-- how do you still infuse
your own voice into something
that you didn't
necessarily make yourself?
JOE KRAMER: I don't
mean to be monopolizing,
so any time you want
an answer, just--
MATT SCHRADER: No, you
take the [INAUDIBLE]..
JOE KRAMER: You nudge me.
Well, I'm not a lawyer.
And I trust the
production to have lawyers
that can vet what I submit.
But there are aspects of
music that you can seize upon.
Because what you're
trying to get at
is the feeling that
the music is creating.
There was sort of a famous
lawsuit in the early
'80s against the video
game Jawbreaker, which--
Namco, I think, accused
of ripping off Pac-Man.
And their argument
was essentially,
if it feels like
you're playing--
even if it's not the little
yellow guy and it's not ghosts,
if it feels like
you're playing Pac-Man,
aren't you infringing
on our copyright?
And I can't remember how
that thing was solved.
What you have to do with
music is sort of go,
what are the elements that I can
emulate without getting sued?
So chord changes-- you can't
copyright chord changes.
Otherwise, every
single blues artist
would be suing every
other single blues artist.
You can't copyright rhythm,
or else "Happy Birthday"
and "The Star-spangled Banner"
would be suing each other,
because--
like, legend has
it, Robert Kennedy
was so tone deaf
that he couldn't
tell if it was the national
anthem or "Happy Birthday"
unless they were
singing the words.
You can't copyright
what key something is,
or what tempo it is.
So right there, you've got
tempo, chord changes, key,
and rhythm.
Now obviously, if you
did all four of those,
you'd be really
pushing your luck.
But those are four
aspects that you
can examine in a piece of
temp, and say, how can I
utilize those in
one way or another
to create the same feeling.
CLIFF REDEKER: And you're also
interjecting your own expertise
as well.
You can say like,
this works out OK.
Here's how I want to
plus or expand it, or--
JOE KRAMER: Right.
Well, and the other thing
is thematic writing,
which I think helps a lot
because if you have themes
for characters, what
you're really then doing
is arranging those themes in the
style of the music in the temp.
CLIFF REDEKER: So, Matt, I
guess, going back to the film
as well, you're interviewing
dozens of composers,
you have a psychologist
that you interviewed as well
for the cognitive perspective.
How did you wind up
selecting the list?
What was it like working
with these different folks?
And also the-- the split between
film scores and TV scores--
like, was that
something intentional?
MATT SCHRADER: Yeah,
and video games, too.
I mean, video games
have become a huge--
huge, I mean, that's a big
deal for composers now.
And you have to
structure it differently.
You have to make something
so that it's kind of--
the score is kind of maybe
collapsible or expandable
sometimes, and it fits
certain story lines.
Yeah, so that's one of-- we
made the conscious decision,
because there's so many
other developing things that
take a very similar model to
what you see in the film score,
including television.
And they kind of
expand on it or they
kind of collapse a little bit.
We thought the film score
is the easiest one to really
comprehend and to get
a sense of how it's--
how you develop something and
how you can come back to it.
There is a certain
kind of rhythm
and a certain kind
of poetry if it's
done right, to the way
that the music should work.
So that, I think
we wanted to narrow
in on that kind
of specific thing.
In terms of the people that
we interviewed in the film,
the music psychologist that
we interviewed is fantastic.
She's one of the
foremost in her field
and has all of these crazy
studies that she's done--
CLIFF REDEKER: The area in
the brain that lights up.
MATT SCHRADER: Right.
I mean, it's that, but it's
also-- it's eye tracking
things.
They've studied
how music effects
where you look on screen.
And she's done some of these
really great tests that
aren't in the film
but she told us about,
about how if you have
really scary music,
you're looking in the
shadows of something.
You might miss
something else entirely.
If you have happy
music-- and there's
this great example from
this film she told us about.
But someone rowing
a boat across a--
across a river or a lake, and
the left side of the screen
is almost all in shadows.
And the way that they studied
where people were looking
for this is, they
had some text pop up
in the shadow that's
like bright red.
You're not going to miss it.
You'll see it for sure.
And when they play the scary
music, everyone saw it.
They said, what's
that text there?
But if they play happy music,
someone rowing their boat
across the water, you
never even look there.
You're following a story
that kind of matches
the feeling that's there, too.
So it shows a little bit about
how things can guide the eye.
And we thought that was
really fascinating stuff.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well
it's also a testament
to the craft that's been
developed over so many years.
It's giving people
an emotional context,
like playing with the theme.
I mean it's operatic onscreen.
MATT SCHRADER: Yeah.
Just the stories that you
can feel through the music.
CLIFF REDEKER: And I also--
you also spoke with the
session musicians, the editors.
And Joe, you can
speak to this for you
personally, or more
broadly for the other folks
that you work with.
Is there a sense of
a recurring team?
Do composers have
a choice of which
session musicians to work with.
whether they go to Abbey
Road or down in LA, or--
how does that work?
And does it influence
the process?
JOE KRAMER: It definitely
influences the process.
You know, there's two--
I mean, I guess the
first way to answer
the question is, there's two
general ways that composers
work.
They either get a
creative fee, and then
the recording and all of that
stuff is handled by the studio.
Or they get what's
called a package deal.
And generally in a
package deal, it's
all the composer's
responsibility.
They're given the
music budget and told
come back with the score.
You'll find with a
lot of package deals
that composers have mixer,
orchestrator, musicians,
studio, everything
where they like to work.
In this context, I mean
the recording studio
where they record it.
And then you'll find
with a creative fee,
it's often dictated by
if it's a union film we
need to use a union orchestra.
If it was Princip-- like in the
case of "Mission Impossible,"
because it was all
done in London,
it made the most sense to
record the score in London.
If it had been done
in LA, there may
have been union
requirements that insisted
that we should score it in LA.
And then if it's a smaller,
independently financed film,
they're not going to have the
means to afford the union.
And you do get--
to a certain degree, you
get what you pay for.
And when you go with a top
notch union orchestra like LA,
you're getting top
notch performance.
And when you have to
cut corners on the cost,
you're usually
making up for that.
CLIFF REDEKER:
Something's got to give.
JOE KRAMER: Yeah.
Something's got to
give, and then you're
going to spend more time mixing
and editing the performances
to get a usable recording.
It helps to know who
you're writing for.
Certainly in the case--
say, "Harry Potter,"
John Williams has a longstanding
relationship with a keyboardist
named Randy Kerber, and he's
got this crazy thing where
the guy's on the [INAUDIBLE]
going [MUSICAL SOUNDS]
for like, 30 seconds--
just all over the place.
And he sent it to Randy like
a month before the recording
session and was
like, I think you're
going to want to practice.
But he knew he was
writing it for Randy,
and there's a video on
YouTube somewhere of Randy
going like, I got it and it
was just all [INAUDIBLE],,
I was like, ohh.
Like, it was a lot
of notes, you know.
But you wouldn't
necessarily take that chance
if you didn't know who
the keyboardist was
that you were writing for.
Certainly on a
film, where you've
got to get it done in a fairly
remarkable amount of time.
When it's a concert
piece and you
know that the orchestra
will have time to rehearse,
you can take more chances.
CLIFF REDEKER: And the
film also made a big deal
about the composer in the
studio looking at the recording
as it's happening,
versus the composer right
out there leading
the orchestra along.
Do you have any preferences?
Do folks come into
familiar styles?
Does it really have an
impact on the output,
whether you control more
from the studio or not?
MATT SCHRADER: Well,
composers definitely
hear it differently
in different places.
In some-- Joe's an example
of someone who gets--
I mean, I guess I'll
let you answer this.
There are some
composers that want
to hear what is being
recorded through everything,
so that they know
what you're getting.
They maybe know
what they can work
with in all of their editing
and mixing and everything else.
But there's also, I mean--
Joe gave an example
of this in the film
and also John
Debney did as well.
But there is a feeling
among a lot of composers
still that they really
want to conduct,
because you are there
with the orchestra
and you develop a little
bit of a connection
and can influence the way
they play certain things
and can correct things if
they're not necessarily
being done the completely
the way you want.
I'll let you explain it.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cuts out
the middleman, I guess.
JOE KRAMER: Yeah.
I was just going to say it.
If I'm sitting in
the booth and I've
got Pete Anthony conducting,
and I want something
changed I have to tell Pete,
who then tells the orchestra.
And that can work.
And that does work
for a lot of people.
But personally-- there's two
things for me, personally.
One is that, just
how many chances
am I going to get to
conduct symphony orchestras?
So every chance I get,
I'm going to take.
And then the second thing
is, I wrote it and I know
how it's supposed to go.
And when they play it and it's
not right, I can address that.
And it's not because
they don't know--
I mean, they're sight
reading this stuff.
I'm throwing-- if you've
seen "Mission Impossible"
Rogue Nation," there's
a three minute sequence
with a motorcycle chase.
And I wrote that on Saturday
at 2:00 in the afternoon,
and we were recording it
Sunday morning at 11:00.
And the orchestra
was sight reading it.
And take one could
have gone in the movie.
I mean, these guys
are top notch.
But they're sight reading.
And so what I'm trying
to give them technically
as a conductor,
that a person who
didn't write the music--
because the conductor,
then, is sight reading, too,
if they're not the composer.
What I'm trying to give them
is, this is what's going on.
They are looking at
50,000 notes, playing.
They're hearing a click
in their headphones.
They're playing along-- diddle,
diddle, diddle, diddle, diddle,
diddle, diddle, dana nana
nana nana nana nana--
and then just, out of
the corner of their eye,
they're keeping an eye on
me as I'm going like this.
Dana na nana nana, dana na.
And what I want them to
get in that split second
that they look at me is, if I'm
going, then they go, oh, wait,
I've got to back way off.
It's communicate--
it's almost like dance.
Like, I'm communicating
through physical motion
where they should be on a
sort of emotional VU meter.
And if everybody's
sight reading,
you're now losing a take,
essentially, to that.
Do you know what I mean?
And time is money.
And you're trying to record--
I did a score for a
television program last month,
and I recorded two hours
of music in two days.
I mean, we had to fly.
So every five minutes I
can save by not having
to do an extra take,
that means in the end
I got an extra episode
done, essentially.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
Nice.
And I guess also, to move on
to another part of the process,
is the creation
of the soundtrack.
I personally find the remade
"Thomas Crown Affair" one
of my all time favorite movies.
I loaded the soundtrack,
and there was maybe
a hint of the melody, but not
a whole lot of what I actually
remember hearing on film.
How do those decisions get made?
What are you influenced
by when you're
creating the soundtrack
versus the movie score?
MATT SCHRADER: We
encountered-- this
is one Joe can answer for sure.
I think you talked about
it briefly in that--
in the scene.
But there is a different
mix that you have.
And we've actually encountered
a lot of people, as we've--
as this film has started
to be released that say,
I love that the
end of whatever it
is, "Space Cowboys" or
whatever-- but the soundtrack
is completely different.
It's not the end of it.
That's not the right music.
They did something else.
They took out this,
they took out this.
And there is a different way
that that typically composers
will treat a soundtrack
as opposed to the film.
JOE KRAMER: Yeah I mean, the
movie has to work as a film.
And there are--
Douglas Adams, I think,
made a great comparison
of film making--
the guy who wrote "Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy,"
where he said, getting
a film made in Hollywood
is like cooking a steak by
having 100 people walk past it
and breathe on it.
And it is like that.
It's slow, and it's tedious,
and you never see any progress,
and then suddenly
the thing is done.
But 100 people have all breathed
their shtanky breath on it.
You know what I mean?
And the music is no exception.
So the director has
what they want for the--
start with the composer.
The composer has a
vision for the score.
The director has how they
want the music to be.
The picture editor has been
working with the director
since the beginning.
They're going to chime
in their two cents.
In the case of
"Mission Impossible,"
Tom Cruise is both producer
and star, so he has an opinion.
The producer-- but the
production company, Sky Dance
has an opinion.
Paramount has an opinion.
Perhaps they--
somebody at Paramount
might think, oh,
would be so great
if we get to have Sting
do a song in this movie.
So now suddenly
Sting is in the mix.
And it's-- nobody's necessarily
got a sinister motive.
But they're all thinking
of ways, and what they see,
and how they could help.
So if you have a vision as a
composer for a piece of music,
film music is not for you.
It's very much like, if
you're a painter, they go,
I want that wall blue.
And you go, well, I really
think it should be red.
I don't care what you think,
I want that wall blue.
The scene needs it to be blue.
And you have to trust that
the director is looking
at the whole big picture and
understanding, yeah, OK, that
is blue for a reason.
So the soundtrack album,
which has nothing to do--
necessarily have anything to
do with pleasing a director
or pleasing producers, it can
exist to please the composer.
And so I look at
the soundtrack CD
as an opportunity to show
my vision for the score,
or as close as I
could get to it.
MATT SCHRADER: Do you think
that reveals something?
Do you think that
reveals something?
JOE KRAMER: Yeah.
In "Mission
Impossible," I recor--
I sometimes recorded two
different versions of a queue.
I recorded the one that I
liked, and I recorded the one
that the director
wanted for the film.
So for example, right in
the beginning of the film,
there's a scene where
a character pops up.
And I had a little tune that
went like bum, dabadum, daba
dabadum, dabadum bum, dabadum.
And it drove the
director crazy--
for whatever reason, he
couldn't different-- he
couldn't listen to the dialogue
with that tune playing.
And what finally
satisfied him was
to have it go bum babadump,
diba dabadum, babadam bum--
so it didn't change notes.
Which underneath the
dialogue you didn't really--
it worked OK.
But on CD, I was like,
I'd rather have the one
that changes notes because it's
more interesting when there's
no dialogue on top of it.
So a great example,
too, is the movie
"Alien," where the
score in the film
is a hodgepodge of rewrites,
and music cut from other films,
and classical music.
And the CD is actually sort
of Gerry Goldsmith's vision
for what he thought the
score to "Alien" should be.
Now it can be frustrating as
a fan, when you see a movie
because you just see the movie.
You don't know all this
other stuff took place
and you're going,
I love that music!
And then you get the
album and it's not there
or it's different.
And you're like-- you know.
And the other thing that's
not so much an issue now
but used to really
be an issue is
that you used to have to
pay the orchestra twice.
Once to use the
music in the film,
and then if you
wanted to put it on CD
you had to pay them
again, the same amount.
That was called the reuse fee.
And one of the reasons
that London started
becoming an attractive option
for American film studios
was that they--
they got rid of the reuse fee.
So if you recorded
a score in London,
you could do whatever
you wanted with the music
when it was done, whereas
in America you could only,
you know.
So a lot of soundtrack
albums, the movie
would have 90 minutes of score.
And they'd put 28
minutes on the CD
because that's all they
can afford to repay.
So you'll see a lot
of [INAUDIBLE] scores
from the '90s, they're
like 28 minutes
long because that was the sweet
spot where they could afford
to pay, but still make a profit
enough to make more scores.
CLIFF REDEKER: So then do
you write that in the liner
notes or something?
Like, this was my vision--
how can the casual fan
understand or realize
all that stuff.
JOE KRAMER: Well, I would argue
there are no casual film music
fans.
I would argue that--
CLIFF REDEKER: Ringtones.
JOE KRAMER: Yeah, well, I would
say if you're a film music fan,
you're probably somewhat
fastidious about that stuff
anyway.
And it depends.
I mean like a
movie like Titanic,
most people probably bought--
the reason that had
phenomenal sales
is not because of the score,
no offense to the composer.
It's because of the song.
Like "Beauty and the Beast,"
everybody bought that album
really for the songs,
not necessarily
for Menken's
admittedly great score.
So when you're part of--
it's very rare that you have a
thing like the original "Star
Wars" LP that goes whatever
it did, double platinum
or whatever.
I mean, i was the best
selling soundtrack album
until "The Bodyguard" I think.
And there were no songs,
you know what I mean?
But that was very rare.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
So we have time for
some audience questions.
So feel free to--
I guess we have one off the bat.
We're short on mics, so tell
it to me, I'll repeat it,
and we'll go from there.
So the question, just
to repeat for the folks
at home was, about the scores.
Are they becoming
less memorable?
Is that a trend?
Is that intentional versus
"Wizard of Oz" or something?
JOE KRAMER: How nerdy do you--
an answer do you want?
CLIFF REDEKER: We
are a nerdy bunch.
JOE KRAMER: OK.
Steven Spielberg used
to make films on Super 8
in his neighborhood
in New Jersey,
in his neighborhood in Arizona.
He'd make-- he'd make
his version of Iwo Jima.
And it was a bunch of
13-year-old kids in blue jeans
and green t-shirts with like
a plastic helmet that they got
at the Woolworth's.
And then when he'd
show his silent movie,
he'd play the record with
the orchestral score.
And you had to make such a
cosmic jump in suspension
of disbelief to buy
that these kids were
fighting on the sands of
Iwo Jima that the score--
he needed all the
help he could get.
So having this score
play worked for him.
And that became a kind of
musical scoring for his films
that he was comfortable with.
What happened is, in the
'80s, with like, "Sex, Lies
and Videotape" and
then the explosion
of independent cinema, you
had people making movies
where these homemade
movies were starting to be
acceptable on their own terms.
Instead of trying to make
an assault on Iwo Jima,
they were making a movie
about five guys hanging out
at the diner.
And so these films actually
could get released.
And in order to get
released, needed
music that could be cleared.
So you couldn't just track it
with sophisticated film music.
You had to find somebody who
could write the music for you.
And so you found somebody
from a rock band,
generally, down the
street who played
keyboards, who could
write instrumental
music for your film.
And they may not
have ever thought
of being a film composer.
They may have just thought,
I'm the keyboardist
in the bar band.
And they end up scoring
a movie by basically
writing instrumental songs.
Not necessarily writing
a theme and counterpoint,
thinking about orchestration and
arranging in the sort of sense
that Goldsmith and John
Williams and Elmore
Bernstein were raised in.
They're coming at it
from three chord rock.
And the epitome of
that was Hans Zimmer,
who really rock and
rolled the film score.
And the strings are
the rhythm guitar,
the horns are the lead singer,
and the percussion section
is the drummer.
And the bottom of the
low strings are the bass.
And then there's
synthesizers and
actual, literal, electric
guitars in there, too.
And in conjunction
with that approach
from the composing point of
view, the filmmakers got--
their musical voice became
this rock and roll vocabulary
rather than operatic film music,
classic golden age film music
vocabulary.
So they didn't think that--
they didn't make films
with that sound in mind.
Spielberg makes a
film, he's thinking
of what John Williams
is going to bring to it.
When Soderberg
makes a film, he's
thinking about what
Cliff Martinez is
going to bring to it.
You know what I mean?
And they're going to bring
two totally different things.
So I think in that
long winded answer
is the germ of what
you're hearing, which
is that the approach now is
much more about background
instrumental music
than necessarily about
thematic storytelling from a
more conservatory, educated
musician.
And I hope I said that without
insulting that other approach,
because I'm not knocking
the other approach.
They're just two
different approaches.
And I think the memor--
what makes music
memorable is a theme.
I think first and foremost,
it's the theme, or the tune,
not necessarily supportive
string sustained chords.
That's a texture more
than a memorable theme.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
Cool.
All right, so there's
three questions.
We'll go here and
then back around.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CLIFF REDEKER: The
cook's in the kitchen,
and how much input you have
when you create a score,
pre-packaged versus voices?
JOE KRAMER:
Christopher McQuarrie,
who directed "Way of the Gun,"
"Jack Reacher" and "Rogue
Nation Mission Impossible."
So three-- three biggest movies
I've done have been with him.
He had some experiences
where he was really
frustrated on films
that he'd written,
where the score sounded
a lot like the temp.
And so he devised, as a film
maker, and approach-- at least
when I worked with
him-- of no temp at all.
He cuts the film based on
the performance of the actors
and the writing of the
dialogue, and gives it
to me with no music.
And what's liberating
about that is,
I can make my own statement.
What's daunting about that is,
there's no guidance whatsoever.
And if I start barking up one
tree and Chris hates that tree,
I've got to come all the way
back down and find another tree
and start working up that one.
So there's a lot of--
there can be a lot of--
not wasted energy, but
there's a lot of work
that is done that
never goes anywhere
because it was the wrong route.
Where temp can really help
is when it gets rid of--
when the filmmakers have
explored their options
and have decided no, this is
the direction we want to go.
That can help a lot.
So OK, we know it's going to
be orchestral symphonic music.
It's not going to be
jazz, and it's not
going to be rhythmic
electric guitar rock music.
OK, well, that helps a
lot just to know that.
I'm trying to think
of a film where
we had so many people on
it with differing visions
and I'm actually kind
of drawing a blank.
I mean--
CLIFF REDEKER: They're
probably weeded out
before the process had started.
People jump on the ship.
MATT SCHRADER: The
studio heads have
stories like that, where even
they noticed that they've
had input from this person,
this person, this person,
this person.
It all ends up being kind
of this mish mash of idea.
Something that maybe you
could see some potential,
but it never kind of came to
fruition because everyone's
like, you do that, you do that.
Robert Kraft at
Fox would tell us
how everyone thinks
they're an expert in music
because we all like
music for the most part.
So we're all like, oh,
well, I would do this.
I like this.
I would do this.
And to a composer,
that is sometimes
something that kind of
restricts what you can do,
if someone says,
well, I really like
this that's what we should do.
JOE KRAMER: The other
mistake is thinking
that you have to-- either as
a composer or a filmmaker--
like the music.
The job is not to make music
that we like, necessarily.
It's to make music that works.
So I heard an anecdote about
one of the Star Wars films
that wasn't directed
by George Lucas.
And somebody who was
brought on was like,
but I don't really like
that John Williams music.
And they were like, it doesn't
matter if you like it or not.
It's not about that.
That's the kind of
music these movies need.
Whether you like it or
not, it's been proven,
that's the voice of these films.
So maybe you like--
maybe you don't
listen to that for fun
and maybe you don't enjoy that.
But that's irrelevant.
If you're making an
action film but you
don't like to drive
fast, that doesn't
mean you'd make
everybody drive slow.
Do you know what I mean?
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
And so we had some
other questions,
we'll do the back,
back, and front.
So go, you, yeah.
Yeah.
MATT SCHRADER: It's
very similar, yeah.
CLIFF REDEKER: And just
to rephrase the question--
and so, to rephrase the
question, the idea of remakes
is composers imitating
themselves, taking extracts
from one film,
putting it in another.
We had some other
examples listed.
JOE KRAMER: Well, as a
composer-- and then I'll go--
we have a voice.
You know, I have a
way of saying things.
When David Mamet
writes a script,
and he writes another
script, there's--
or Sorkin, you know.
There's a voice behind that.
And there are certain
gestures, you might say,
or musical ideas that
are going to recur.
To give maximum benefit of
the doubt to the filmmaker--
to the composers in the
situations you mentioned,
I would say that
they were probably
encouraged-- heavily
encouraged-- by the filmmakers
to stick as close to a piece
of temp music as they could.
And sometimes it's easier
when it's your own stuff,
and sometimes it's
harder actually
because you can't see
the forest for the trees.
See what I mean?
Now, I'm going to show
some ignorance here.
The Max Richter stuff was
written as concert music,
wasn't it?
And then tracked into the film.
So that's-- right, so
that's slightly different,
because I think it's also
in "Shutter Island," right?
Do you know?
But I think it was--
it's like Arvo Part.
It was written for the
concert hall, I believe.
I could be totally wrong.
Right.
So I mean, like you'll
see Habanera from Carmen
is in every-- dan dan
danan, dadan da dadan.
You'll hear that.
It was in "Scent of a Woman,"
but it's in everything.
You know what I mean?
Where they take a piece
of classical music
that they love and
they use in a film.
But then somebody sees that
and loves that and goes,
oh, that's classical music?
I could just use that?
Great!
And then you'll see cases where
the composer was encouraged
to copy the temp and
they just couldn't do it,
so they've gone and
bought the temp.
So like in the movie "Die Hard,"
when the blond bad guy jumps up
at the end of the movie,
you think he's dead
and he jumps up with the
gun and starts going nuts--
they just bought the
music from Aliens
that they had temped
in, because for whatever
reason, the director
and the composer
could not come up with
a solution together.
CLIFF REDEKER:
Actually there is a--
on the topic of voice,
because we entered this film
with the idea of, OK, I
know what a Hans Zimmer
score sounds like.
I know what-- you know, there
are a certain number of people
I can always--
almost always, I should
say, identify John Williams.
I can, a lot of the times
identify, Danny Elfman.
I can usually identify
Thomas Newman.
A lot of these guys have a
very kind of a signature style
if they're given--
you can do anything in
the world for this film,
it's still going
to sound like them.
And we tried to tap into
that a couple of times,
including at Hans--
we kind of wanted
to know what Hans sounded like.
And so we-- but we thought
about this with a few composers.
Some composers
struggled with it,
but we asked them to
just play something
and didn't give them
any direction, really,
but kind of wanted to
see where they went.
And a few of them--
usually on a piano-- but a
few of them, including Hans,
you can tell--
and it's in the
end of our movie--
but you can tell from
the chords that he picks,
it sounds very Hans Zimmer.
It's a lot of long, kind
of sustained chords.
But even the direction that
he goes in making something up
for-- this is
something for nothing,
it's just some people with
cameras pointed at him.
It's never going
to air anywhere.
But it sounds like
the progression
that he would use in a movie.
So you can almost
identify even that,
something that's 30
seconds long-- oh, yeah,
that sounds like Hans Zimmer.
So I think a lot of composers
do have that unique voice
that you can pick up on
even if sometimes it's
directly used in another
film, but even if it's not.
CLIFF REDEKER: And speaking
of the unique voice,
too, if you look at the
"Mission Impossible" suite,
how do you approach
composing each one?
Like, there's a core
theme from the TV show
that kind of has to be there.
But are you-- do you
feel forced to make
something sound
completely different,
or do you like a
sibling relationship
between the films, or--?
JOE KRAMER: Well, to speak
specifically about Mission,
I actually-- it
drives me nuts when
you go to one of these
reboot or sequels
and they've gotten
a different composer
from who did the original.
And they try to put the
music from the original in.
And it usually ends up
sounding like they've literally
just gone and gotten the sheet
music from the first movie
and handed it to all
the musicians and said,
just play this.
As opposed to
actually organically
integrating that
into this new score.
And so with Mission, it was
really important to me--
it didn't necessarily
help my career,
but it was really
important to me
that you couldn't
necessarily tell
where Lalo ended and I began.
Because I didn't
want it to be like,
oh, it's Joe Kramer, Joe Kramer,
Joe Kramer, Lalo Schifrin!
Brilliant!
Joe Kramer, Joe Kramer,
Joe Kramer-- you know.
So I worked really hard to--
when Lalo would come in and out.
So, I mean, I embarked on a
sort of reverse engineering
of the theme.
And breaking it down
into its core pieces,
and then using those core
pieces kind of like refrigerator
magnet poetry to create
new music for the film.
And as a result, my hope was
that what you would get is--
yeah, it's the same words,
but I'm making new sentences
with those words.
CLIFF REDEKER: And for the
documentary "King Cohen"
that you're working on, too,
it's an historical perspective.
It's things that
appeared on screen,
so it suggests
something already.
In a sense it's a
documentary medium.
Do you just feel compelled
to go with the flow?
Or how would you
strike out on your own?
JOE KRAMER: Well, you
know, that was a movie--
to the gentleman who had been
asking about too many cooks.
It wasn't necessarily that
we had too many cooks,
but there were two interesting
things on that film.
One was that the filmmakers
were big film music fans.
And so they were very excited
to finally get a chance
to actually help create--
participate in the
creation of a score.
And I kept having to tell them
like, guys, this film, we're
not necessarily going to be
making music you actually like.
Like, I just wanted
to warn them.
And in a documentary, music
can often be just practical.
What we're doing is, we're
cutting in and out of a movie.
And we cut-- we have
a scene from a movie,
then we have a
talking head, and then
we have another
scene from the movie,
then a talking head, and then
another scene from the movie.
And it sounds weird
to have the score--
because a lot of
these movies were
done so long ago and so
cheaply that we don't have
the original elements anymore.
We've only got the
finished movie.
So there was no way to get the
dialogue without the score.
You know what I mean?
It was all or nothing.
So what I had to do was
composed little bits of music
that could go under
the talking head
to glue the whole
thing together.
So that you'd come out
of a clip from the movie,
I'd have the music in
a sympathetic chord
and a similar sound
play under the dialogue,
and then come back for the
thing, for the next clip.
And sometimes they liked
that and sometimes they
didn't, and then--
I actually haven't
seen the finished film.
So I don't know how
they ended up doing it,
because I gave them
a couple of choices.
But yeah, it was a
practical thing there
of just trying to make
stuff glue together.
There was another
film I worked on where
they had a thing from SNL,
and they could get the clip.
It was for a Ralph
Nader documentary.
They could get a
clip of him talking,
but they couldn't
use any of the music.
So when they came back from
commercial with the screen
and it's the bluesy sax
stuff, I'd make all that
and then figure out
a way to get out
of that and into the
dialogue from Nader.
So it's practical.
CLIFF REDEKER: Right.
So I think we have
two final questions.
So we'll go with Bob Hurby, the
president of the Mountain View
Film Society first.
True or not, did
Hitchcock hate the--
JOE KRAMER: I haven't
heard that he hated it,
but I do know that he was
really happy with what--
and Hitchcock's a great
example of what I talk about.
In modern film, this--
the hauteur has
sort of run rampant.
And now everybody on a film is
there to realize the directors
vision.
And what I'm supposed
to do is write music
that the director would write,
if he could write music.
And what Hitchcock did was,
he was like, I'm not even
going to try to write music.
Bernard Hermann knows
what he's doing.
Let him write music, and even
if it's not what I'm expecting
or what I want, when I hear
it, oh, yeah, that's great,
I never-- you know.
So I do think that he
was impressed with that.
I do know they had
a falling out, so--
but I can't say for sure
that he hated the shower
scene until he saw it.
I do know that Joe
Stefano, I think
it is, who wrote the book--
they had a screening
of the rough cut
before the score
was done and Stefano
after the screening was like,
oh, my god, it's terrible.
And Hitchcock was
like, no, no, no, wait.
This is the rough cut.
When you see it with
the music and the sound,
you won't-- it'll be
a different movie.
CLIFF REDEKER: So our
last question in the back.
How do you [INAUDIBLE]
your workload?
JOE KRAMER: I work
in Sonar on a PC.
I'm the only composer I know
who does that, but I learned it
when I was young and I just--
old dog can't--
I could learn logic.
I could learn-- my music editor
is constantly on me to learn
Cubase and maybe I will.
But for now, I fly on it,
because I have all my hotkeys
programmed that all that stuff.
So what I do is,
I watch the film.
We have what's called a spotting
session, where we discuss
where we think music will
be and where it should go
and where it'll be quiet, and
what the music will kind of be.
Will it be a sad score?
will it be-- is it a sad movie
where we want a happier score
to help offset that?
Or is it a comedy, where we want
the music to actually be like--
again, this latest
project is a comedy.
It's a sort of satire on
cop shows from the '80s.
So I did everything
acoustically like a late '70s,
like "Rockford Files" or
such, you know, "SWAT."
And the music is very straight.
If you hear the music
away from the film,
much like the score
to "Airplane."
If you hear that score
away from the film,
it sounds like it's a disaster
movie, not for a comedy.
So we'll have that discussion.
Then I live with the film.
I watch the film as
much as possible.
Sometimes with the temp,
more often without the temp,
and just start to learn
the rhythm of the film
and pick up on connections.
Something the character says
here that pays off there,
you know what I mean?
And I start thinking about--
I have a whole series
of sort of mnemonics
that I go through
in my brain to help
me start coming up with ideas.
So if it's a heroic
character, the theme
is probably going to
be kind of uplifting,
and it's going to have
intervals in it of leaps.
If it's a sad movie,
then it's obviously--
if it's a laconic sort
of dour theme, that
might be almost like a waltz,
but a sad, minor key waltz.
And I develop this
material and I
keep a journal on
the piano, where
I write all this stuff down.
And then usually when
they're so mad at me
that I haven't shown them
anything to picture yet,
I then finally start
working to picture.
And I've got-- what I've got
is like a cheat sheet of all
this thematic notation
that I've done.
And I start drawing
stuff up against it
and seeing what sticks.
And then I start
making the cues.
And at that point,
I've got my time line
where I go, OK,
I've got to do 15
seconds of contemplative
music, and then
he makes the decisions.
So then it becomes 20
seconds of definitive music
as he marches down the
hall to talk to his boss.
And then he goes in
the boss's office
and the boss is running
around with the secretary,
so it's funny music
for a few seconds.
You know what I mean?
So at that point-- and I'm
doing all this stuff in Sonar.
And I may-- I have a template
set up that mimics a symphony
orchestra or whatever
ensemble I'm using
for this particular assignment.
And then I create a
mock-up that sounds
as real as I could make it sound
in a reasonable amount of time.
And I then do as much of that as
I can for as much of the movie
as I can.
And then I have the
director come over,
and we just watch it, from
beginning to end, like a movie,
with as little
interruption as possible.
Then we roll back and
start going through,
measure by measure,
scene by scene,
however it used to
be done, to discuss
what works for the director
and what doesn't work.
Now what I found
recently is helping
a lot is to actually
just email it to them.
Have their editors
put in the film
and let them live with it for
a week before we talk about it.
Because often what happens
is, the first thing they think
is, it's not the temp.
It's not the temp,
and now everything
I hate about the
scene, I hate again,
because the temp fixed it all
and this isn't fixing it all.
And it's not that.
It's that they're just seeing
all the flaws, because that's
what they--
they made this thing
and they can see
all the cracks in the paint.
John Lennon hated
Sergeant Pepper, but he
was the only one, because
he could see all the--
he could see behind the curtain.
So what I find is, if I let
them live with it for a week,
then a lot of that panic
that they got goes away
and they actually start
looking at it on its own terms
and saying, no, all right,
I see why you did that.
I see why you-- and we
couldn't do that with the temp,
because no one else
had done that before
and we couldn't find a piece
of temp that turned that way.
There's a back and
forth of revision.
When the queue is locked up--
I'm sorry this is so
long winded-- that
is sent to the orchestrator
as a MIDI file.
They open it up in
Sibelius or Finale,
and they then adapt
my MIDI performances
into notation which is then
printed out and distributed
to the musicians at the session.
And that can happen, like in
the case of the motorcycle chase
in "Mission Impossible,"
that had to happen
in less than 12 hours.
MATT SCHRADER: The
orchestrator doesn't sleep.
Not very much.
JOE KRAMER: But they know.
It comes with-- they
get paid for that.
CLIFF REDEKER: Awesome stuff.
Well, I invite you all to
check out the documentary.
We'll have it up on Google
Play, wherever movies are shown.
And of course, now
I hope you have
an even deeper
appreciation for the music
and the themes behind
the score of the film.
So, Matt, Joe, thank you
very much for speaking
with us today.
MATT SCHRADER: Thank you.
CLIFF REDEKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]